it may have been a home where children
once played or perhaps a roadside
business that helped parents put food on
the table maybe a guest house for
passing tourists
whatever it was it is now and forever
part of a massive debris field that runs
the length of the malamchi river in
sindhupalchak district
in valleys across nepal homes and
businesses have been swallowed up by
major floods
three times this year
weeks on from the latest delusion
october the number of dead and missing
is still rising and the list of damaged
and destroyed buildings is getting
longer
many nepalese have been living in limbo
for months
[Music]
is a mother and a grandmother she and
her husband invested everything they had
in trout farms that sat at the river's
edge
a trade they had hoped to pass on to the
next generation what they spent years
building was gone in a day
my son and husband were trying to save
the farm but then we had to run as we
were watching flood waters came and
swept away all the trees and we took the
kids and escaped the next morning we
came back to have a look and everything
was gone
her daughter bema ran the family cafe
which also became a casualty of
unseasonably extreme weather she says
she now feels lost
i could not have even imagined what
happened we sacrificed a lot to build
that place and it didn't even last two
years i'm very sad about that
thousands of people across nepal just
like bhima have lost everything and are
trying to rebuild their lives from
scratch
families displaced by the floods are
living in these makeshift camps for now
but they're waiting for more
semi-permanent housing to be built
further uphill now that's going to be
made out of corrugated metal sheets not
necessarily the best protection against
the coming winter cold but even though
the river has receded the idea right now
is to get as far away from the water
line as possible and onto more solid
ground but even uphill that may not be
so easy to come by disaster management
experts are warning that areas in the
himalayan region that saw heavy rains
are now at greater risk from landslides
zain basravi al-jazeera sindhu palchak
district nepal